the crucible knight definitely not an
easy boss to deal with you can get this
guy early game or late game just like
the rest of the game but you'll likely
come across this boss pretty early and i
am here to tell you that this boss is a
lot easier than he comes off every
single attack he does is dodgeable just
by rolling so when you learn his moveset
that i will show you in this video this
boss really is not that hard there is a
stage two to this boss that makes it a
little bit more difficult since he now
has a magical tail that will swipe you
randomly and really quickly and he grows
wings and flies right at you it's just
lucky enough that all of this guy's
moves are pretty easy to dodge like i
said in the video i'm going to be
showing you how to effectively dodge
every single attack this guy puts how to
survive phase two and you'll likely get
to a point where you won't take any
damage from this boss with enough
practice if you want to take a shot at
it he's right here on the map near
stormgate castle good luck gamers oh we
can definitely do this bro
we can
okay just reset
it's a bad [ __ ] heel man
this guy really doesn't give you
anything
[Music]
it's okay
i was expecting a tail
[Music]
nice
nice
come on
[Music]
nice
two is greedy but doable
okay that's such an early phase two from
him but okay
he brings out the tail if you want to go
for two now
i wonder if i can parry him when he
comes down there that'd be sick
[ __ ] and he was like too high
should have seen a common voice
my bad
nice
faster
[Music]
i want to use my thing
gives me a little buff
probably are kyle
[ __ ] man i i suck against the shield
come on give me give me one second bro
one second
okay
thank you
okay
cool
[Music]
nice
that was such an like he wasn't even
close to me man
[ __ ] come on
so
random
when is it like when's the last time you
did that like five minutes ago right at
the beginning of the fight
bastard
three
come on
[ __ ] you
[Music]
come on boys
[Music]
there it is
let's go
good fight
good fight
now i can do the tail cool
good
fight